a bigger question that we talk about is
disruption right there's disruption with
Bitcoin disrupting the financial markets
with politics with Trump's disruption
with YouTube and Spotify and podcasting
disrupting mainstream Legacy Media is
the writing on the wall for someone like
Tucker saying I don't need this
mainstream media
corporate cow Towing to these types of
corporate sponsorships and basically
hand time what I can say I can go do
what Megan Kelly's been doing I can do
what pbd's been doing I can do what
Rogan's been doing I could do what
Russell Brand's been doing I could do to
him I own bring my own audience with me
and make my own money how much of that
do you think is factoring into this
situation